foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again my little movie review series
so Martyrs from 2008.
this was I kind of feel like this is one
of those movies obviously whose
reputation
precedes it unquestionably and I kind of
always felt like it was something that I
probably should watch you know being a
big horror nerd like I am but I have to
say that up until this point like every
time that I went to kind of place it on
the review schedule it's like oh I'll do
it next week or whatever
um I would always kind of end up
chickening out and like watch something
that was less I guess like notorious
maybe I mean don't get me wrong I've
watched plenty of [ __ ] up movies uh
and for the most part they don't
generally bother me as much as probably
they should to be honest with you but
Martyrs kind of seems like one of those
movies that turns up on pretty much
everybody's list of most disturbing
films ever and for a long time I guess
like when it came time to like review it
I was just never really in the mood to
sit through it so I was kind of change
it out for something else now I did
manage to I don't know how I managed to
do this but in preparation I guess like
for the unknown future day when I would
eventually sit down and watch it because
I I knew that I would at some point I
did manage to not really read much of
anything about it just like for all
these years so the plot wouldn't be
spoiled for me and actually now that
I've watched it I'm actually glad I
really I'm actually really glad that I
did that because one of the best things
about the movie in my opinion is how it
kept like constantly blindsiding me and
went in directions that I wasn't really
expecting it to go so anyway obviously
since I'm doing this video uh you can
surmise that yes I finally did settle in
and watch the thing and uh you know yeah
I I get it now I mean this movie and
like I said I've seen some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and I don't even know if this is if
I'd call this the most [ __ ] up movie
I've ever seen but it's definitely one
of the most nihilistic movies I've ever
seen and one of the hardest to sit
through
um I don't think I'd call it gory in the
way that something like the sadness or
you know terrify or two or something
like that is Gory it's not like that but
it's certainly brutal like and the
brutality I feel like is largely a
product of the realism and just the
unrelenting nature of its violence and I
kind of feel like I even watched like
after I watched it I watched some other
horror channels like reviews of it and
even the most hardened horror fans were
like man that's kind of messed up you
know what I mean so this one's kind of
messed up uh it's kind of expert level
if you're just a casual horror fan I
don't really know if this is really
something you want to be watching but
you know what I mean
um I'm actually glad I watched it but I
don't imagine that I would ever be in
the mood to sit through it again which
in some ways is kind of like the highest
praise that you can give to a horror
movie because it did the job that it set
out to do right I mean it horrified me
it disgusted me it revolted me it put me
in a dark mental place so you know Kudos
I guess so to talk about this movie to
any kind of like depth at all I'm gonna
have to spoil what happens in it and
like I said I would recommend if you are
gonna watch this I mean I can't like I
said just across the board recommend it
because this is very much like if you're
super into horror yeah I can recommend
it then but if you're just a casual fan
probably you don't want to like you
don't want to go there
um because it's not a pleasant
experience it's not a fun time it's not
an entertaining horror movie you know
what I mean I but I do feel like if you
are gonna watch it it's better going
into it not knowing where it's going you
know what I mean so uh this is your
final spoiler warning I'm gonna tell you
like pretty much all the [ __ ] that
happens in the movie so martyrs which
was written and directed by Pascal
longier and he admits that he was at a
very dark place in his life when he uh
wrote and directed this movie and it
shows
um and I but I feel like this movie
often gets lumped in with the you know
the new French extremity movement but I
don't know I feel like uh Pascal lagier
really didn't like that term and I kind
of feel like he was trying to do
something else with it because this
movie does actually have a deeper
philosophical bent to it that somewhat
justifies its really kind of like [ __ ]
up like disturbing visuals now I'm not
gonna say that doesn't make them any
easier to stomach because there's a
point to it but I do kind of feel like
there is a point to it it's not just
[ __ ] up [ __ ] for the sake of being
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you know the savagery in
this is near constant and it's like just
very very realistic so it's kind of like
sickening in that way but it's all for a
purpose like I said you never really get
the sense that this movie is just
showing you messed up things for the
sake of titillation or entertainment or
thrills or anything like that it's
showing these you these images like
specifically to disturb you and make you
uncomfortable and it really does succeed
in doing that very very well so at the
beginning of the film I believe it's
1971 and there's a young girl named Lucy
who has been held prisoner and you know
sadistically tortured for about a year I
think they specify so at the very
beginning of the movie she actually
escapes from captivity and kind of just
runs screaming into the streets
so the authorities take her to an
orphanage uh where you know
unsurprisingly she has kind of a hard
time overcoming her Trauma from this
year of abuse that she underwent
there is one other girl at the orphanage
known though named Anna who actually
befriends Lucy and takes care of her
like in a very motherly you know best
friend kind of way and she kind of
slowly becomes Lucy's I don't know if
I'd say like she's her only Lifeline but
she's like her closest friend her you
know the only girl that she actually
ever confides in or anything
so because of these two girls real close
friendship the police actually ask Anna
to relay any information that Lucy might
have shared with her about the person or
the people that abused her because
obviously they want to catch these
monsters but Anna will only tell them
it's like oh Lucy doesn't really
remember anything like about the
experience she wouldn't be able to
identify them anyway because it was
always so dark
we also learn that Lucy is seemingly
being tormented by some kind of demonic
looking woman who may or may not be real
so the story then skips ahead 15 years
and we're introduced then to this kind
of upper middle class family the belfons
uh they kind of seem about as average a
family as you're ever likely to see like
at the beginning like you meet them the
mom Gabrielle is kind of like outflick
fixing the water pump or whatever
there's like a dead mouse in it uh the
dad who I don't think is ever named is
making breakfast for everybody uh the
teenage son and the daughter who looks
like she's maybe about 11 or 12. they're
kind of like squabbling back and forth
like siblings do so it all seems very
very ordinary but as you're watching it
you're kind of like you can't help but
be on edge a little bit because you're
like who are these people and what do
they have to do with the young girl that
we saw escaping from captivity at the
beginning of the movie well just hang in
there because you're gonna find out soon
enough
so not too long into this you know just
a very average Domesticity kind of like
situation the doorbell rings and when Mr
belfond goes to answer it Lucy who's
obviously 15 years older is standing on
the doorstep uh aiming a shotgun at him
and uh really he doesn't get a chance to
say much of anything before she very
coldly just blows him the [ __ ] away
Lucy then comes into the house and
proceeds to slaughter the whole entire
family even the kids though she does
seem to feel a little bit bad about it
but it's almost kind of like she's
operating like she doesn't have a choice
you know what I mean so after
perpetrating this horrifying horrifying
Massacre which is like I said very
realistic and very disturbing to watch
Lucy calls Anna on the phone now Anna
has supposedly been waiting in a parking
lot nearby and she clearly was not quite
prepared for what Lucy did
what you find out is that Lucy Had
suspected that the belfons the couple
were the people who had tortured her as
a child and although the plan was
ostensibly that she was just gonna go to
this house to make absolutely sure that
it was them before taking Revenge by the
way she had actually tracked them down
through like there was a newspaper
article about the daughters I think it
was like a swimming Championship or
something like that and it had a photo
of the whole family and she recognized
them so that's how she knew like where
they were like how she tracked him down
but once she got to the house she said
she told Anna that she was certain that
that's once she saw them she knew that
that's who it was so she then just
proceeded to wipe them all off the face
of the earth now keep in mind that this
[ __ ] happens all of this happens like
within like the first third of the movie
and so as events are unfolding I kind of
found myself
simultaneously intrigued by but also
kind of dreading like what was gonna
happen next this is one of those movies
where it's like you just kind of sit
there with a knot in your stomach the
whole time because you're not really
sure what's gonna happen
so Anna like comes to the house and
starts to help Lucy get rid of the
bodies
we also see that this demonic woman uh
who has apparently been plaguing Lucy
since childhood is still with her and we
now have come to understand that this
woman is actually just a manifestation
of Lucy's guilt and her former trauma
and she only exists inside Lucy's head
like nobody else can see her obviously
um but to Lucy though she's very real
and she has actually killed the belfons
in order to appease this woman though
she's kind of like confused as to why
the woman is still around and is still
like tormenting her even though
supposedly all of the abusers are dead
so Lucy and Anna while they're kind of
like trying to clean up the scene or
whatever they kind of run into something
of a snag while Anna is dragging the
bodies out into the yard she discovers
that the mom Gabrielle is still just
very very barely alive
now Anna decides that she's going to
help this woman because you know
probably deep down she doesn't condone
what Lucy did and I kind of feel like
she may not even entirely believe Lucy
that these were indeed the people who
tortured her and the movie kind of like
plays with the audience in this way too
because Lucy is presented as not really
the most stable person like I said
understandably given her history and
we're kind of also doubting it's like
maybe these weren't the right people
like maybe she got it wrong like maybe
she was just mistaken or maybe she's
completely delusional we don't really
know but you're kind of led to believe
that maybe Anna's thinking along those
lines too and that's why she decides
well I'm gonna try and like at least
save this one woman because the other
three are already dead now Lucy though
catches Anna trying to help the dying
woman Gabrielle and she basically gets
really mad like she accuses Anna of not
having her back she's like you don't
believe me just like the doctors didn't
believe me and then she proceeds to bash
in Gabrielle's skull repeatedly with a
hammer and uh yeah I I was really
wincing watching that [ __ ] like I said
it's very very realistic it's very very
difficult to watch so yikes uh so now
the alleged abusers are really all dead
and Lucy kind of has a moment like with
her demonic counterpart person ghost
whatever uh she's kind of like hugging
her but then the demon woman kind of
like slices open both of her arms like
long ways like all the way down which
again is very difficult to watch and
starts like bashing her head repeatedly
into the wall now when we see of this
events these events occurring like
through Anna's eyes we can see that
obviously Lucy is doing all these things
to herself now it's actually made clear
through a flashback that happens like
right around this time period that the
demon woman that Lucy has been seeing
all these years was actually another
victim of the torturers from back then
so so when Lucy escaped their clutches
she saw this woman chained to the wall
and the woman was like you know looking
at her like hey please help me but Lucy
was like nope I'm out and she just like
left her there and so like all of these
years later I mean she was just a kid
what are you gonna do
um all these years later like she still
feels guilty that she left that woman
there so this you know the spirit of
this woman or like a manifestation of
this woman has been like haunting her
like all this time so Lucy then crashes
right out the house like through a
window and stands in the yard and slices
her own throat open so that's right the
person that you thought was like the
main character of the movie is now dead
and it's only about halfway through what
the actual [ __ ] you may be asking
yourself well strap in because if this
thing was difficult to watch before now
it's gonna jump right into like the next
level of [ __ ] up business like so you
know here we go
now so while I'm sitting there watching
this movie wondering what the hell is
going on and contemplating whether or
not like the belfons actually were the
tormentors that Lucy suspected them of
being because I was like how's this
going to go is she going to find out
that oh it wasn't really them and like
all this other kind of stuff
so while all of that was going on
Anna actually discovers a secret passage
in the belfon's home
which leads down to a big huge kitted
out basement uh and it has all kind of
like really upsetting photos like
mounted on the wall like their beautiful
artwork there's all kind of like weird
medical equipment and rooms and stuff oh
and also there's a cell where a naked
woman is chained to the wall who by the
way is also sporting this kind of metal
device of some kind that goes kind of
like over the top of her head and like
around her eyes like kind of blocking
her vision and did I also mention that
this contraption is also nailed to This
Woman's skull yay so Anna obviously
horrified realizes that Lucy was right
about the belfons all along they were
these abusers and they're doing it to
other people too
uh so now you as the viewer start to
feel hey maybe not so bad that Lucy just
came in and like blew them all the [ __ ]
away I mean killing the kids was still
kind of [ __ ] up because they might not
have known but you know what I mean uh
you know you know you don't feel bad
about her like blowing the way blowing
away the mom and dad
so Anna actually tries to help the woman
by freeing her from her chains and like
putting her in a bath which obviously
probably really hurts a lot because
she's all covered with cuts and stuff oh
and she also like takes the screwdriver
and like prized the metal thing
out of her head
it was like it's really really hard to
watch I was like watching this one other
review of IT where like a guy and his
wife were watching it and they had like
just audio they couldn't show any of the
scenes obviously because YouTube would
you know demonetize it or whatever but
um they just had it kind of blurred out
and then they had like their audio
reactions to it and they're just not
like screaming and going ah you know
what I mean it was like so so funny but
it's like just the sound they made so
that's kind of what I did too I was like
oh Jesus Christ so yeah uh the the thing
when she pries it off also I guess it's
been on her face so long that it's also
like fused to her face like to the flesh
so it's always good it's very gooey oh
my God it's like it's it's horrifying so
the woman I mean is freaking the [ __ ]
out like I said understandably like I
don't know how long she's been in there
um and at one point she kind of like
runs off into the house she finds a
knife and starts to saw one of her own
hands off so and that also looks super
super realistic and I was like Jesus
[ __ ] Christ it's horrifying it's a
horrifying movie now in the midst of
This Woman's episode if you want to call
it that uh a completely shocking event
occurs I was not prepared for this by
any stretch of the imagination
this random woman who we haven't seen up
till now strolls in to the house through
the front door and just blows that woman
away just blame just shoots her and
kills her just [ __ ] call me please
and for a second you're thinking okay
who the [ __ ] are these people like are
these the authorities did somebody call
the police like is Anna saved is all you
know and then I'm just kind of like you
find out later
sadly the answers to those questions are
no no it absolutely not because it turns
out that these people who have just
arrived because behind the woman that
shot the hysterical woman uh are a bunch
more people who just stream in like they
own the place and they're just kind of
like oh yeah well we've been calling the
belfons and they didn't answer so we
figured there was some there was
something going on over here so we
thought we'd come check it out so they
come in
so it turns out that these people are
essentially members of like a cult of
which I don't know if I yeah I guess
he'd call it cult kind of and the
belfons were actually enthusiastic
devotees of the of said cult so these
people who are all like kind of look
upper middle class or wealthy they seem
like mostly middle-aged or elderly they
have spent their whole mission
they've spent years and years seeking a
true martyr not in the sense of somebody
dying for their religious beliefs which
I feel like is the more common uh
definition nowadays but in kind of the
original simpler
um you know definition of like a witness
you know what I mean
they are convinced that if you put
someone through enough pain and torture
then that person will eventually like
transcend life like transcend their body
and be able to see what lies on the
other side of the veil as it were
so the leader of this cult who is only
ever called Mademoiselle who's like an
older lady she shows Anna because of
course the Anna's in here so they chain
her to the wall too and they're like hey
check this out so they have like this
[ __ ] photo book of [ __ ] that they
show or say all these photos of still
living people who had endured the most
just unimaginable Agony but they had
this like particular look in their eyes
that suggested that they had kind of
born witness to what lay Beyond Death
they had like transcended you know so
because these cult people are just
obsessed with knowing what happens after
you die they've been torturing young
girls and women for years including Lucy
when she was little they're looking for
a tree martyr that will be able to
endure all of this pain and just be able
to tell them in no uncertain terms what
will be in store for them like after
death and they do say at some point that
they've had like three or four uh girls
that did actually transcend but weren't
they weren't able to like tell them what
they saw and you know what I mean but uh
so as you can probably guess because
they found Anna here in the belfon's
house they figure hey here's our next
test subject we don't even have to go
out and kidnap everybody it's you know
it's kind of like doordash but for
torture victims so yeah uh the final
third of the movie is just Anna as she
is repeatedly just beaten and abused
over and over and over and over and over
again it goes on for a very long time
and it is very very agonizing to watch
uh but again like I said that's kind of
the point of it like the audience is
essentially being put into the same
position as the victim is being kind of
brutalized past the breaking point for
the sake of like a higher purpose so the
movie is kind of like meta that way now
some undetermined period of time later
when Anna has just been so beaten down
and abused that the cultists are just
like certain that she's gonna transcend
at any time now they tell her there's
only one more step to go like your
suffering will soon be at an end
now can you guess what this final step
is
go ahead guys
oh my God so uh if you guessed gee I bet
those cultists are going to strap Anna
into this big metal frame Contraption
and Flay all the skin off her body while
she's still alive then you get a cookie
because that's what happens uh they do
leave the skin on her face though so you
know that was thoughtful of them
so after this horrific event oh and can
I say too that I just really want to
give props to the astonishing
astonishingly realistic and very very
grotesque special effects work here I
mean some of the best that I've ever
seen it was actually done by a guy named
uh benoitang who actually sadly uh
committed suicide like before this movie
came out which is pretty [ __ ] up
so yeah so after this whole skin playing
incident
one of the cultists goes down to give
Anna some food and she sees the look in
Anna's eyes and she screams she like
calls Mademoiselle and she's like you
guys need to get all of the other
members of The Cult here like yesterday
because this girl has transcended like
she because they can tell like by the
look in their face she's our first true
martyr and we do actually see some kind
of like like transcendental imagery
because they show things like from
Anna's perspective like as she's kind of
like gazing out into the Beyond or
whatever so all the cultists are super
excited and they all like gather at the
house they're all dressed in their
Sunday Best and everything like it's a
big [ __ ] party and uh the this guy
who's like the second in command I don't
know if they ever said what his name was
so he tells all these people that Anna
has indeed transcended and has actually
been able the first person that they've
uh had to do this she was actually able
to share what she saw with Madam was out
like she saw what she you know she she
told her what she thought like beyond
the Beyond or whatever
Mademoiselle in fact uh says the second
in command guy is like she's gonna come
out momentarily and tell all of you guys
like what she said like we've all been
waiting years to hear this this is the
culmination of all of their Grim toil
like all of those poor children and
girls and women that they tortured this
is this is what's this is what we've
been wanting like all this time so mad
was out she doesn't really seem to want
to come out uh so when her second
command Lieutenant guy like knocks on
the door and is like hey what's up
she asks him can you really really
imagine what lies Beyond Death
and the guy admits that he can't imagine
it
and then Mademoiselle says to him
through the door keep doubting and she
blows her own face off with a pistol the
end that's the end so obviously uh this
ending can be and has been interpreted
in multiple ways because we as the
audience are not privy to whatever Anna
told Mademoiselle only she knows that so
could it be that there was nothing at
all beyond death and Mademoiselle
realized that her group had tortured and
killed just countless people for no
reason
was there in fact a pure and beautiful
afterlife that Anna did indeed see but
that Mademoiselle and the other cultists
would never attain because all of the
evils they had perpetrated to learn that
information
uh on the other hand was the afterlife
so awesome that Mademoiselle felt the
need to get there right away and she
thought she would [ __ ] with the
co-cultus heads on the way out or maybe
she thought they would all kill
themselves too like to get there faster
if she told them what was going on
uh the also the possibility is still
there too that um did Anna actually lie
about what she saw as like a final [ __ ]
you to her captors which you know that's
possible also I mean I've read loads of
different theories about what what the
ending of this meant and to be honest
I'm not really sure which one I
subscribe to I'm kind of leaning toward
the explanation that Anna did
unequivocally like see heaven or see
like a beautiful afterlife but then
related to Mademoiselle that none of you
[ __ ] are ever gonna get there
because of what you did like to attain
that knowledge thereby making all of the
[ __ ] that they did I mean not only evil
but also like ultimately pointless so
yeah uh Martyrs is a rough movie to
watch for sure
um but I actually weirdly found it kind
of rewarding and because I guess because
it was like so thought provoking uh you
know the experience was it's you know if
if the description of it tells you
anything it's obviously not for the
faint of heart or the week of stomach
and honestly if you never feel the need
to sit through it because you don't want
the images from it or the ideas from it
rattling around in your head I
absolutely would not blame you one bit
but as extreme art goes it's actually
pretty magnificent and I'm gonna say if
you can persuade some like-minded
friends to watch it with you you can
have all kind of fun discussions about
what the ending meant like in between
kind of like squinting your eyes and
like look at his [ __ ] like through like
this just to give yourself a break from
like the unrelenting like bleakness and
cruelty of this movie by the way there
was an American remake of Martyrs in
2015 uh because of course there was
that's just any kind of like foreign
film that did any kind of business
they're gonna do an American remake of
it but from what I've heard the American
version is substantially toned down from
the original and though I have not seen
it uh it gets pretty dire reviews across
the board so I'm gonna say like if the
concept of the movie interests you then
just go ahead and watch the French one
watch the original because uh it's
probably like a million times better so
happy you seen Martyrs what did you
think about it do you not want to see it
now now that I've told you what happens
in it or if you have seen it what do you
what's your interpretation of the end
because I'm interested in other people's
theories about it and that will do it
for this flickers of fear I'll see you
guys again on the next one bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]